we're so excited for Ally because we're
so excited for a tasty that's because a
make-a-wish that I'm going to tasty this
is a very big deal
my name is Justin wing and I'm 16 years
old I am a heart transplant recipient
recovery post transplant was tough but
months later I became so much better and
I was determined to live a healthy life
and cooking became a big part of that
make-a-wish approached me I learned I
had a make-a-wish and I decided to make
a cookbook the goal of the cookbook was
for me to live a healthy normal life I
got the idea to make a video of tasty
because I am an avid tasty fan today is
a very special day for me I will be
partnering up with Katie to make
Justin's heart healthy tell me first I'm
gonna give you a tour and then I'm gonna
take you to at the tasty of our room and
we're gonna make a video are you excited
yeah okay great
well just right this way okay this is
where all the magic happens this is a
lot by seeing the tastiest space it was
a lot more chill than I thought it'd be
and it made me feel very comfortable
being there this is the camera and then
we'll watch everything up in this
monitor right here oh when we H showed
up I was shocked I think I kind of
freaked out of it she is a normal human
being which I did not expect she made me
feel so welcome she took a picture with
me and I want to get her autograph
yeah I'm chummy
oh maybe she'll come to test some your
food when we're done oh yeah would you
like a moon okay yeah 30 to make it
fancy so this is the pantry maybe we
should grab a few things for the
yeah so I think we would need some tongs
absolutely oh my god Oh many nine oh my
god probably need a bigger bowl right
for young adult star to hang out in so
in here this is the tasty bar room
that's what we call it and this roller
Big Show's happened when I walked into
the tasty stage I he recognized oh my
god this is where Alvin cooked and this
is where we ate cooked and this is where
Alexis cooked and then this is what
we're gonna make our video I am super
excited to make chow mein with Katie
today and being on taste he's like a
dream come true I am a little nervous
about making the tasty video but I think
Katie will instruct me today I'm gonna
be showing you how to make heart healthy
a chicken chow mein I picked it because
chow mein is a very popular fast food
recipe that's typically unhealthy has a
lot of oil has a lot of soy sauce I
wanted to make it heart-healthy and I
think that for us transplant patients we
don't want to give up those delicious
foods recovery post transplant cooking
became a stepping stone to exercise it
may not seem a lot to you but to me
grabbing the pots and pans going to the
pantry to grab some ingredients and
going to the freezer to grab some more
ingredients and back to the stove was a
lot of exercise when I couldn't even
barely walk cooking for me is an
essential part of my health and vital
towards my lifestyle that I am living
today working at tasty OHS juggling two
things at once we had to keep on cooking
Wow looking up at the camera monitor his
seat if we were in the right positions
and it was a little bit difficult but
Katie really guarded me well and go
oh so good high five okay Wow mmm I love
the flavor the garlic is the garlic the
garlic is really coming through and the
thing is you had low sodium soy sauce
okay but it still has tons of flavor
how did it go yeah it was fun oh sorry
job he's a natural somebody porch thank
you Ravens I think create is one of the
tougher grater is a food app tasty so
the fact that she liked it really made
me happy you take the stand on the
leftovers okay yeah we can do that yeah
oh my god
[Applause]
I was a little nervous for other people
to try my food but when I came in people
were like applauding and that made me
feel better and they all said it was
delicious and you know we spent like
four hours making food for something
cleared out in 30 seconds although I
would say that the day went excellent
this has kind of been you know my dream
to go on here and there's just so many
great people here and I love cooking
here my message for people watching is
that I'm a life because my donor said
yes to donation there are so many people
in our hospitals of waiting for
life-saving organ transplant please go
to donate life dotnet and sign up to
become an organ donor
[Music]